tenemos tres de cuadrada más seis x al
cubo y estamos elevando este binomio a
la quinta potencia claramente podríamos
utilizar el teorema del binomio o el
triángulo de pascal para encontrar la
expansión de este binomio a las cinco
pero lo que quiero que hagamos en este
vídeo es que nos fijemos en un solo
término de la expansión porque hay
tenemos por aquí toda la expansión y en
algún punto vamos a llegar a un término
que tiene x a la 6 porque a las 6 por un
coeficiente por aquí y después otro
bonche de términos pero lo que quiero es
que encontremos cuál es este coeficiente
de aquí y te recomiendo que le pongas
pausa al vídeo y trates de encontrarlo
tú solito bueno estoy suponiendo que ya
lo intentaste y pues la primera vez que
lo vemos podemos confundirnos un poquito
no o sea porque tenemos equis a la 6
porque a las 6 y como base si estamos
elevando un binomio a la quinta potencia
que tengamos estos exponentes igual a 6
y luego te fijas adentro del paréntesis
y ves que tenemos aquí una ye cuadrada y
una equis a la 3
y entonces todo empieza a tener un poco
más de sentido ya considerando que
tenemos ya al cuadrado y equis a la
tercera potencia todo eso elevado a las
cinco ya podemos pensar en que tengamos
por aquí un término cuyos exponentes
sean mayores que cinco pero bueno para
encontrar cuál es este coeficiente de
este término primero hay que entender un
poco qué patrón sigue la expansión de
este binomio a las 5 tomando en cuenta
esa extensión sin preocuparnos por los
coeficientes y ya después vamos a ver
cuál es el coeficiente que corresponde a
este término y bueno esto de la
expansión de un binomio a las 5 ya lo
hemos visto un montón de veces nada más
tenemos que poner por aquí el primer
término
es cuadrada y lo elevamos a la potencia
a la que estamos llevando al binomio o
sea a las 5 pero antes de ver lo de los
exponentes déjame copio esto y lo pego
unas 6 veces
porque el número de términos en una
expansión de un binomio a las 5 siempre
es el número del exponente en este caso
5 más 1 y luego tenemos que multiplicar
por 6 x al cubo en este término está la
0 y déjame lo copio y lo pego en el
resto de los términos
ahora sí vamos con los exponentes aquí
este lo tenemos que elevar la potencia 5
este a la potencia 4 3 2 1 y 0 y los
exponentes de este término empiezan en
cero van a 1 2 3 4 y finalmente 5 y por
supuesto se están sumando
y además de sumarse cada uno de estos
términos tiene por aquí un coeficiente
ok ahora cuál de estos términos
corresponde al término que tiene x a la
6 x llega a las 6 a ver si tomamos este
término por aquí tenemos ya al cuadrado
y luego todo esto a la cuarta potencia y
eso pues nos va a dar una a la 8
necesitamos una ya las 6 no una llega a
la 8 entonces vamos a ver si este
término nos sirve tenemos aquí ya al
cuadrado y luego a la tercera potencia
eso nos da una idea de las seis y de
este lado tenemos x a la 3
y todo eso al cuadrado o sea que tenemos
x a las 6 entonces este término de aquí
este de aquí es el término que tiene x a
la 6 porque a la 6
entonces nos interesa muchísimo saber
cuánto vale este coeficiente
claro que hay que notar que el
coeficiente que pongamos aquí no es
precisamente este coeficiente que
estamos buscando que falta tomar en
cuenta otro detalle muy importante sin
embargo este coeficiente de aquí lo
podemos encontrar muy fácilmente
ok porque tenemos aquí una expansión de
un binomio a las cinco y este es el
primero segundo tercer término de esa
expansión así es que ir pues podemos
utilizar el teorema del binomio o el
triángulo de pascal para encontrar este
coeficiente entonces hay que encontrar
este coeficiente y una vez que lo
encontremos para sacar cuánto vale esto
que estamos buscando lo que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar el coeficiente de
esta multiplicación ok porque aquí hay
un 3 a la 3 y aquí hay un 6 a la 2 y
esta cosa que estamos buscando está
absorbiendo todos esos números pero
bueno vamos a empezar por encontrar este
número de aquí
aunque hoy podemos usar el triángulo de
pascal o podemos usar combinatoria y
pues vamos a empezar por combinatoria
entonces aquí el coeficiente de este
término son las combinaciones del número
al cual estamos elevando al binomio que
en este caso es 55 son las combinaciones
de 5 en el número al cual estamos
elevando el segundo término del binomio
que en este caso es un cero
0 y ahora vamos con el segundo término
aquí este coeficiente son las
combinaciones del número al cual estamos
elevando el binomio que es un 5 y son
las combinaciones de 5 en el número al
cual estamos elevando el segundo término
del binomio que en este caso es un 1 y
ahora vamos al coeficiente que más nos
interese y son las combinaciones de 55
en 2 en 2 y bueno como que aquí no se ve
muy bien entonces voy a escribirlo por
acá son las combinaciones de 55 en 22
eso es igual a 5 factorial entre 2
factorial 2 factorial por 5 menos dos
factoriales ok es 55 menos dos estados
factorial así es que vamos a desarrollar
cuánto vale estas combinaciones de 5 en
25 factorial es igual a 5 por 4 por 3
por 2 y aquí le podríamos poner por 1
pero realmente no cambia nada aunque
sabes que vamos a ponerlo de una vez
para no confundir nada y luego aquí
abajo tenemos 2 factorial que es un 2
por 1 y por aquí tenemos 5 menos 2
factorial y esos cinco menos dos es 33
factorial es 3 por 2 por 1 y podemos ver
que hay un bonche de cosas que se pueden
cancelar no o sea este 3 se cancela con
este 32 se cancela con 2 los unos no
afectan el valor de nada y este 2 está
dividiendo a este 4 y 4 entre 2 es 2 así
es que nos queda 5 por 2 y 5 por 2 es 10
así es que este coeficiente de aquí las
combinaciones de 5 en 2 es simplemente
un 10
entonces este coeficiente de aquí es un
10 ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
encontrar este coeficiente pero usando
el triángulo de pascal aquí empezamos
con un 1 después tenemos dos nuevos es
un 11 este es el binomio solito elevado
a la potencia 1 y después tenemos por
aquí cuando elevamos el binomio a la
segunda potencia y nos quedan los
coeficientes 11 + 1 21 llevamos al
binomio a la tercera potencia y los
coeficientes son 13 31 elevamos el
binomio a la cuarta potencia y nos
quedan 1 4336
4 y 1 y finalmente el quinto nivel que
es el que realmente nos interesa 11 454
6 10 10 5 y 1 entonces si queremos el
coeficiente del tercer término a ver
aquí tenemos un término segundo término
tercer término de la expansión de un
binomio a la quinta potencia lo que
tenemos que hacer es irnos al triángulo
de pascal al quinto nivel bueno donde
este es el nivel cero nos vamos a este
nivel y buscamos el tercero término y
entonces este es este coeficiente de
aquí así es que los dos métodos y
coinciden entonces ahora sí ya vamos a
tratar de encontrar este término y lo
que tenemos que hacer es volver a
escribir este término de aquí pero de
forma desarrollada aunque hay entonces
tenemos por allí un 10 y después tenemos
3 porque cuadrada
y aquí está el detalle del que les
hablaba yo antes tenemos aquí tres a la
33 a la 3 porque cuadrada a la 3 que
simplemente llegue a las 6 x 6 al
cuadrado 6 al cuadrado por x al cubo al
cuadrado y x al cubo al cuadrado es como
x a la 3 por 2 que simplemente x las 6 y
bueno esto es igual a 10 10 por 3 a la 3
que es 27 27 por 6 al cuadrado que es 36
por 36 y finalmente x x a la 6 x a la 6
x que a las 6 x que a las 6 entonces
tenemos aquí x a las 6 x ya la 6 que es
justo esto de aquí y tenemos tal cual el
coeficiente que acompaña a x a la 6 por
llevarlo a 6 así es que tenemos que
calcularlo y listo
tenemos 10 por 27 por 36 igual 9 mil 720
ok estoy aquí es igual a 9 mil 720 así
es que este coeficiente que estábamos
buscando es 9 mil 720 y listo